hello i'm george wilson and welcome to
the british council
in france today i'd like to welcome you
to our bilingual section open day the
bilingual section is a really integral
part of our offer in france we welcome
children from the age of four to 18
whose first language is english these
children speak really well
but they come here to have more practice
and to gain the literacy skills they'll
need as they grow
and develop so today i'm going to show
you just some of the projects that our
biblical students
take part in
so in this corner we're showing off to
our parents some of the books that our
early years students
so those who are four and five
study with us
you can see that the books we study are
designed to promote discussion
to get people
thinking about the stories but also
learning the phonic sounds that will
help them with their writing we also put
a heavy emphasis
on inclusion
in our stories and you can see how
there are lots of positive messages
in the books that we get our children to
study
and read together
so students in our
bilingual seven class are seven and
eight
and they study this book forgotten fairy
tales of kindness and courage
we do all kinds of work with the
literature that our children study
it might be
writing letters to the characters it
might be role play it might be creative
writing but we also get them to use
their hands you can see here a
representation
of one of the fairy tales in the book
i'll let you guess which one it is
in bilingual eight our students are
introduced to the concept of the
environment our programs put our core
skills at the heart of all of our
teaching these are things like
citizenship personal development and
generally being good 21st century
members of society really important to
that
is the environment you can see here
they've created a beautiful tree and
each leaf represents a tip
on how to support the environment and
tackle problems that are so important to
us all
by the time our students get to bible 9
they've got a good level they're really
getting a strong ability in reading and
writing
and so here we've got a challenge for
them
we get them to
learn poems by heart and recite them in
a competition with prizes it's great to
see how well they take on board the
challenge
and they kind of bring the poems to life
there are some brilliant quotes here i
think my favorite was i've learned to
read with my hands and my legs
bilingual 10 are delving into history
and history studies wouldn't be yet
complete without looking into the tutors
our students read a book called terrible
tudors
which is part of the horrible history
series
and at the end of all their studies we
get them to
recreate a banquet fit for king henry
viii or elizabeth the first
our teachers dress up
our students dress up
and
they recreate shakespeare plays dances
and all the details that really make a
good
tudor party
so we are trying to train good 21st
century students
students who care and give back to
society
in bilingual 11 our students study a
book called refugee boy by benjamin
zephaniah and we wanted to bring this
experience to life to get really
involved
in
making sure that refugees are well
welcomed
in france so with that in mind we
partnered with a charity called unia
this is a charity we do a lot of
outreach work for the association
welcomes refugees and migrants to france
and supports them in their educational
endeavors
part of that is providing a library of
reading material
our students designed posters
and interviewed
this woman from uni andy
um to learn all about the program the
posters then
spread the word and encourage people to
donate books
as you can see
the project was very successful we got
hundreds of books which have been very
much appreciated by those members of the
association
[Music]
so bilingual 12
had the opportunity this year to become
pen friends
with
members of our bilingual school in
madrid
we called the project connecting
cultures
and what was really nice about it was
how well the students took to the
project
they saw that this was a real
opportunity to experience culture from
different perspective
to learn about another country and also
just to have that good old-fashioned
connection with somebody who you don't
know
our valuable 13 students have been
studying that classic of literature
romeo and juliet by shakespeare so
to kind of end off their project
we asked them to perform for their
parents
the students used an abridged version of
the plane and collaborated across
different classes
in order to really bring the performance
to life you can see just some of the
photos here it was pretty incredible
and what's been really nice about the
whole thing is their enthusiasm bringing
a text that's so old to life with so
much vivacity is quite an achievement
huge congratulations to the students and
the teachers
[Music]
once our students finish the bilingual
13 they begin preparation for the igcse
in first language english
this is a qualification that will be
used by the learners to show their first
language ability in english when they
come to apply to universities
and also just have a really good sense
of their progression
and their achievement in following our
bilingual section
the exam takes two years to prepare and
in the first year there's still time
for them to take part in a public
speaking competition the learners really
took this to heart and did some
wonderful performances given in front of
her an invited audience some of the
bilingual students were the winners of
the competition and it was also a nice
opportunity for them to connect with
learners from our foreign language
section
once students finish their igcse and
they've got qualification in their
pockets they move on to thinking about
higher education now our learners have
the opportunity to follow a two-year
course known as university preparation
it prepares students to
take part in higher education
in english
our teachers are advisors so they're
able to give advice on the application
process
and the courses are designed to develop
the academic skills they'll need
for their future success
some of the things we do in the course
are quite innovative
we ask students to follow a mooc for
example an online course offered by a
university in this mooc they have the
opportunity to really connect with real
university teaching
at the end of their mooc which they
follow assiduously with um a diary
they produce poster presentations all
about the topics
now these poster presentations show the
sheer range of interests our learners
have
there's one about the sun one about the
marketing process
surrealism and dreams
so there's lots of different subjects
that interest our learners and this is a
chance for them to share their learning
and to show off their readiness for
university in english
[Music]
so our courses in the bilingual section
are mapped onto the british national
curriculum
that means that we've adapted the
program from the uk
to suit the developmental needs of
students in france
we have used a range of different
materials to support us in the same we
begin with phonics work work on
transcribing sounds into writing
and we use this nice series jolly
phonics then we move into the primary
section
where we use books
based on spelling
and books that develop
their general
english
abilities once they move into the
secondary section the books obviously
become slightly more complex
and we have some great material
ready for the learners this goes on into
it [ __ ]
and beyond that we use our own bespoke
materials for university preparation
one thing that's really important in our
section
is our range of literature the way in
which we integrate this into our course
courses
and the way in which we
use this to focus on different course
skills
these books are inclusive they're
dynamic and they're really at the heart
of what we can offer
first language english alerts
thank you for joining us today
on our bilingual open day it's been
great to show you around the british
council in france it's been great to
really show off the work that our
students have done
i'm really proud of their progress i'm
really proud of what we do here and i
hope you'll join us
in the future